[Musique]
euh,
les bâtiments obtiennent une façade de bâtiment
chauffée jusqu'à 45
degrés Celsius
et lorsque nous avons mesuré oasia,
la température relevée
à midi est d'environ 25 à 35 degrés,
donc d'une certaine manière, l'écologisation de l'enveloppe est
très rentable et  pourtant un
moyen passif de
garder un bâtiment au frais
[Musique] l'
Asie est pour nous un prototype d'intensification de l'utilisation des terres
sous les tropiques,
donc contrairement euh à
la typologie scellée des gratte-ciel qui
émergent du climat occidental
euh
cette tour vivante que vous voyez ici est un
effort
pour adoucir  la dureté des villes ainsi
que de ramener
les jardins paysagers et la biodiversité
en ville
[Musique]
vous